relatives who believe their loved ones
may have become cult members have come
to look for them
traveled to the Kenyan Coast from
Nairobi
her brothers disappeared several years
ago after selling their ancestral land
I've been trying to search at the MOG
police took us to the farm we are
waiting and hoping that they will be
rescued
is looking for his daughter she
disappeared three years ago
several people have been rescued some
like this man were weak and dehydrated
they are undergoing counseling
Aid workers say they have registered
more than 200 missing people half of
them children we are shocked because
initially we thought probably these are
very local people from kilifi very poor
people but when we look at the records
that we are receiving today we have
international people here people from
Tanzania people from Rwanda people from
no sorry people from Nigeria and even
Kenyans who are well off coming to all
the way to to to to shakahola
the land in chakahola sits on 300
hectares its remote and far removed from
other villages in the area we found
several homesteads near where the graves
are it looks like any other poor rural
home but there is nothing typical about
this tragedy such comes as scattered
across this area it appears that people
left in a hurry relatives who are here
are saying they are hoping that their
loved ones will be found alive
interior secretary kindikikidure visited
the scene and made assurances that the
alleged cult leader Paul McKenzie may
never be set free I was glad to hear the
director of public prosecution saying
that he is exploring charging Mr
McKenzie and his group
with terrorism
and I want to encourage the director of
public prosecution that is not
far-fetched
to build a case of terrorism from what
we have witnessed
relatives continue to wait for any news
as such and rescue team is on ground in
the village looking for victims who
could still be hiding out in the bush
Catherine soy chakahola malindi Kenya